it was becoming very clear that there
are certain topics that you are not
allowed to research that you're not
allowed to talk about or discuss
even if you are a scientific expert in
the field and
one topic in particular that i had been
following was
the issue of gender transition in
children
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report as always guys make sure you're
subscribed to our youtube channel and
have clicked that pesky notification
bell
and joining me today is a neuroscientist
who specializes in gender
sex and sexual orientation as well as
the author
of the new book the end of gender
debunking the myths about sex
and identity in our society dr debra so
welcome back to the reuben report
hi dave thank you for having me again so
i was checking
right before i sat down to see when i
had you on last and it's
it's almost two years to the day it's
two years to the week
and we were talking about much of the
stuff that you wrote about in this book
gender and the whole lgbt
letter conglomeration and identity and
all of these things
and i remember when we sat down for the
first time that a lot of people said oh
no this trans stuff
this isn't real nobody really cares
about this stuff
all these things these are just made up
things that only academics and you
youtubers care about
flash forward two years to where we're
at right now with your book coming out
this week and it's
like this is one of the biggest issues
around so
i guess my first question is it must
feel pretty good to not be crazy huh
i guess so but i'm just so horrified by
how everything has turned out i mean i
was really
when i saw you two years ago i remember
things were just starting to pick up in
the mainstream
and i was still hoping there's still a
chance maybe this is going to get caught
people are going to figure things out
we're going to be able to cut this off
before it gets too crazy
but it really has just gotten worse and
with the end of gender i wrote that book
really with the hope of trying to again
bring more attention to these issues so
that people might take them seriously
and realize that
you know we're not just a bunch of
fringe crazy people complaining about
things these have real
implications for people's lives
especially for young people
and it's going to be really really
unfortunate and ugly in a few years
yeah all right so the book is really
spectacular and you dive into
what are considered some of the most
controversial topics of the day so we're
obviously going to get to all of that
but for
for anyone watching this that didn't see
our first uh interview
can you just do like a quick two-minute
sort of recap of your bio of how
of your training that led you to to
write this book
right so i when i was in my phd so i
have a phd
in sexual neuroscience research i now
work as a journalist
i write predominantly about the science
of sex and gender also about politics
and how politicization of scientific
research is really
doing society and a disservice and i
also write a lot about academic freedom
because that's becoming
another problem that we're seeing and so
for myself in the last few years of my
phd i had noticed that the political
climate
of academia was shifting and it was
becoming very clear that there are
certain topics that you are not allowed
to research that you're not allowed to
talk about or discuss
even if you are a scientific expert in
the field and
one topic in particular that i had been
following was
the issue of gender transition in
children
and so at that time every single
mainstream news piece pretty much i
could count on maybe the one or two
fingers the number of
pieces that had come out criticizing
this at that time said that the best way
forward
for
children who are gender dysphoric so
they feel they're more like the opposite
sex than the sex that they were born as
the best way forward for them was to
socially transition at a young age
younger being better and that once they
did transition they flourished you know
parents would say that they're doing so
much better
but from a scientific perspective all of
the research
literature suggests that it's actually
better for these children to wait
until they reach puberty there's a very
very high chance that they're going to
outgrow the way they feel they're more
likely grow up to be gay in adulthood
and so i wrote an op-ed about this and i
waited about six months because i didn't
know if i really wanted to publish it
because i knew it was going to be
there's going to be huge backlash
and i asked a number of my mentors and
colleagues what i should do and i
remember one of my mentors said to me
i asked him should i wait until i have
tenure because at the time i had planned
to stay in academia and i had a whole
plan in terms of what i was going to do
in terms of my research and
he said that tenure would not protect me
in this climate so i decided to publish
that piece
and it was uh it was a difficult time
i'm really glad i did it and i write in
the book about you know what that
process was like for me and what it was
like being mobbed really badly for the
first time but
once you get through your first mobbing
you're fine and
you know they can't stop me now
yeah it's funny because uh you know i've
been through my own version of the mob
thing and i feel the same way once you
get through it
you will survive it's your it's going to
hurt it's going to suck all of that
stuff
but once you get through it and survive
you will be stronger on the other side
could you just talk a little bit though
about the reaction
from your colleagues because i'm still i
think a lot of people
can't accept somehow that academia could
be this corrupt that when you
write a paper using scientific evidence
saying that you know when you transition
this young it doesn't necessarily
lead to a happier life and you use data
and evidence to support that
that you still get hit from the other
academics like i think people can't
really the average person who's not in
academia can't really understand
how that happened to academia
well i would say within sex research
which was my discipline
um it really has been like a canary in
the coal mine because we saw these
issues especially
left-leaning science denial this has
been an issue for decades in sexology
which is a scientific study of sex and
gender
so most of us in sexology are liberals i
consider myself still to be a liberal
and and i think my colleagues are just
focused on doing good work as they
should be
so i wouldn't say not that you were
saying this but i wouldn't say sex
research necessarily themselves are
corrupt in
why they stay silent it's more that they
know they already have a target on their
back
usually sexologists are dealing from uh
science now coming from the right
because usually
not everyone on the right is is has an
issue with sex researchers but
historically it's been more on the right
now that it's coming from the left it's
like sex researchers don't know how to
deal with it because
in a lot of cases it's people on the
same side as you and you're
you feel as though is this really as
important as calling out when the right
comes after us
so i think that's one layer of it you
know it's very competitive in academia
and to get a
10-year position is almost unheard of
nowadays so you're very busy
it's stressful and then then you have
these other academics in other
disciplines who are not scientific
not to say that they all have bad
intentions but they're starting to take
over they're the most vocal
and they're getting a lot of support
also i would say by mainstream news
outlets
so it as time goes on it feels i think
more and more
like you have more to lose than to gain
by speaking out so why start speaking
out now
and that's where that's how we got to
where we are so one of the things that
i'm i'm really amazed by and i've
brought this up with a couple guests
when i've talked about the trans issue
i've talked about this with douglas
murray and with rob smith and a couple
other people
is that in many ways the trans movement
now
seems almost perversely anti-gay
meaning that if you're an effeminate
young boy
they would rather see you transition
to be female rather than accept that you
actually are just a gay male so i also
think just for me personally it's
particularly weird because
i played with gi joes and transformers
so the so no one thought i was gay per
se right
but if i hit but i have friends that
played that were boys that played with
barbies and people thought they were gay
when
when they were five and that if they now
even though they're maybe in their 40s
now if they were
growing up now and they were four years
old five years old doing that
they would have been put through
transition and and that seems
sort of anti-gay doesn't it
100 100 and myself as we talked last
time i was with you
i grew up in the gay community i find
this very upsetting if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell